YouTube don't really what people doing
public acts of endangerment no they
don't what is this that's like if you
think about it pranksters who like start
beef with people and start fights like
this like why they should be able to
make money like this why they should be
able to make money going up to people
who living their everyday lives and with
them to the point where they're getting
this upset and then monetizing their
insane reactions it's not like they're
just monetizing people having a good
time no when people freak out that's the
thumbnail that's the title o look I got
this guy so mad I'm about to make
thousands why this guy doesn't get a
dime and I get to cause emotional
distress and I get to make him look
crazy so that everybody who sees him in
his community can also think he's crazy
I'm not going to lie this whole genre
really up self-defense is what a jury
determined in the case of a man who
police say shot a YouTuber during a
prank video at a Virginia mall however
Alan Coley was found guilty of firing a
gun inside the mall a door Dash driver
Coy was on trial for the April 2023
shooting of Tanner cook that case went
viral not because there was a shooting
inside a mall but because cook is known
to make prank videos K's guilty verdict
has been set aside for now though until
a hearing to discuss it is held on
October 19th D found not guilty you want
to see the
video sure of the actual incident cuz
they released
it oh yay yay that prankster who went
around bothering people so we'll see the
video and let's see if it changes is my
mind so let's see what happens viewers
might find this video
disturbing
what my twinkle what's
that about my twinkle
no get my face
stop
stop something just didn't happen to
me something just didn't happen to
me something didn't happened to me to me
nothing
happened to
me it was just nature unfolding for you
to me this a poem in my road it's called
to me to
me [__] around and find
out someone you don't know tells you to
stop you do not stop
yank and he was about to say it's a
prank no
bow it was exactly what I thought it
would be to me and to
me does it change anything to you cuz to
me it does not it doesn't better for me
oh go ahead bro I feel like you could
have just pulled out the gun said back
away I think that would have been a
reasonable ESC you know escalation no
noan no no no just no so pull out the
you have to start shooting I'm not say
you have to start shooting but the the
warning start the warning doesn't start
when the gun is there the warning start
when I tell you to stop it doesn't stop
where stop stop stop
that let's try this again with a gun no
you could have you could have absolutely
I know listen I don't I don't mind
seeing the prankster get shot I think
lowkey kind of feel good
it feel good godamn it does but if you
being honest he could have said now
here's the other side of the coin go
ahead now watching this footage I'm not
going to lie that dude look Disturbed
and that's the guy that you choose to
bug yeah like you see his reaction you
the way he's shuffling and moving he
looks genuinely afraid of the dudes
approaching him he's not taking it as a
joke no right I I can see him by his
body language the dude look genuinely
like afraid of the dude bro you you see
see just the go ahead what I was trying
to say is like this is why I said you
don't know who you're messing with you
don't know who it is you pranking when
you trying to turn random strangers who
are like working their dead- end jobs
and just trying to go about their date
and you're trying to use them for your
content and you're doing this little
little twinkle thing whatever you don't
know what kind of childhood trauma
you're trying to pull out of this person
so you can make money it's funny to you
it might even be funny to your audience
it's not funny that people being pranked
how is that enjoyable this person didn't
pay an admission to come to standup
comedy show this person didn't show up
to an event being like Oh it's for
pranksters they didn't show up to your
show they didn't show up to your live
event they're working a shitty job doing
delivery you don't know what the [__]
they going through and you pressing
their buttons come to find out oops that
was the nuclear button that was you mess
with the right
one
James to the front door right now please
James James hi you man come hello Jam we
need to speak to James is this where the
study group is no what number is
this this is not where the stud got kids
man oh you got kids oh sorry oh I
thought this was the study gr actually
nice dog she's lovely
she's G
out outside I didn't hit you I just shot
on your oh oh oh oh oh whoa oh W wait oh
yo you got to chase him oh
oh oh he said go outside
yo video bro it was just it was just a
video y it yo it was just a video care
what you doing bro to my mother I I yo
yo relax yo it's a video yo it's a video
yo what do you mean I buy this no wait
what's going on I scan it you're taking
that from me
what what what excuse me yo what's up
wait what happened I buy those stuff
those groceries those are mine you
[__] hearing man you see could he
have had better escalation sure but
maybe he's not all up there did you ever
consider that like if I pull the strap
on a homeless person I'm not expecting
10 steps of escalation you know what I'm
saying
like you don't know especially like how
I've seen mental health issues boom up
in people who like I genuinely see her
crazy and unmedicated it's not
surprising that this went like
that was it kind of quick and also to be
fair I don't know if there was more
before this video cuz the video starts
they're already in this dude's face so
there could be more before which would
change the way I feel about it I
remember when they were doing when they
did the there was an article yeah
remember there was an article they said
that before doing that yes they were
looking at dude they were looking at the
guy staring at the so no it does not
start there when you look at the article
of what had happened they said and they
stated that they were looking at the
dude in a certain way before I'm going
to pull it up so we can hear in the
footage cook approaches the shooter in
the mall's food court area gets close to
him and follows him for approximately 60
to 90 seconds okay now I will say if the
60 to 90 seconds look like that in the
video pop off I think it's impressive
you use one
bullet that's a long time when you're
easy and when he was following it wasn't
like he was at a distance he had a phone
in the dude's face playing some kind of
childhood [__] and then just following
the dude dude is taller than him looks
[__] Shifty no if you just this ain't
a Girl Scout following me okay this a
this ain't basket Robins what are you
talking about a girl scout following me
like that is scary she knows something I
don't why are you following me first off
I don't want none of your cookies and
then you're following me Twinkle Twinkle
twinkle twinkle I'm shooting you too hey
B you know damn well you can't shoot no
Girl Scout I'm shooting her too no you
can't shoot no Girl Scout you trying to
go to jail for 10 life sentences listen
cuz you know little white girl's life
was with how many human lives st stop
talking crazy I'm still saying you can
run I'm still saying I can run I can run
I could punt mother you can fake out you
can turn off the lights yeah but this
keep pushing this is right no listen it
was a fult I don't know what the
[__] had yeah I'll give you I'll
give it to you so listen no the
escalation
the warning doesn't start once you see
the gun no I already told you to stop I
was not feeling it other thing out of
all the people this is who you choose to
[__] go after the way that guy that's
who you to me through
me to me it's something that happened
it's just something that happened
whatever I'm going to say something
crazy oh I don't even like saying it but
I'm going to say something I really feel
in my chest YouTube don't really [__]
with people doing public acts of
endangerment no they don't what is this
that's that's like if you think about it
pranksters who like start beef with
people and start fights like this like
why they should be able to make money
like this why they should be able to
make money going up to people living
their everyday lives and [__] with
them to the point where they're getting
this upset and then monetizing their
insane reactions it's not like they're
just monetizing people having a good
time no when people freak out that's the
thumbnail that's the title oh look I got
this guy so mad I'm about to make thous
why this guy doesn't get a dime and I
get to cause emotional distress and I
get to make him look crazy so that
everybody who sees him in his community
can also think he's crazy I'm not going
to lie this whole genre really fed up
it's they don't make these people sign
no waivers most of the time they don't
make these people sign nothing and these
people don't know how to actually sue
them properly because they don't know
how to have the legal Avenues right so
nothing ends up happening but if you
think about it YouTube pranking is
actually one of the more [__] up
genres that exist on the platform I'm
just saying there's some mad tasteful
about it it is mad is distasteful is wet
yeah what what and people are
celebrating cuz this guy got off on the
charge but he's getting he's still
getting charged for discharging a
firearm inside a mall which is kind of
counterintuitive to me cuz if they quit
him on the self-defense chares he would
charg like like like you're saying oh
self-defense is acceptable but not using
a firearm in self-defense like huh maybe
I don't know the state law so whatever's
going on might be very like but it just
doesn't make sense to me that oh yes
self-defense is legal but not in the
like what why would that be the case I
don't understand that's because you're
not supposed to have a proba maybe in
that area you're not supposed to have a
gun on you a gun with maybe you're not
supposed to have a gun with you so they
understand the charge where it's uh
where it's like he was defending himself
but you're not supposed to have a fire
if he's not supposed to have a firearm
and it's charging it in public like that
yeah that's wild like for example if I'm
here in Canada I that could happen here
cuz I'm not supposed to discharge a
firearm in public but if I feel you feel
like that I feel I'm going to be charged
for one but probably not the other you
understand what I'm saying but to me
what happened okay acquitted and and and
homeboy doesn't care he say he's going
to keep pranking people he's going to
keep doing it and like I said if this
dude loses his life most people just
going to celebrate they won't care a bad
person who goes around doing bad things
to strangers and doesn't care about how
they feel about it whatever happens to
that kind of person I just don't care to
me is just I'm not I'm personally not
going to celebrate but I'm not going to
feel bad I'm just going to be so
indifferent no it's like if you want to
go be a terrible person to other human
being like why should I mourn your death
that's for your family to do they care
about you I don't give a [__] the same
way you don't give a [__] about others
apparently the same way that Daddy was
about there yeah you know what this and
that your dad was like really behind you
and everything and stuff like who raised
you listen I'm all for comedians Ro than
people but I wouldn't be Downs with a
comedian just running up on the street
to random strangers filming them and
then roasting them like as a comedian
like I just I don't think I don't [__]
with that these people just going about
their they they sign up to come to your
show it's fair game they know what they
paying for these are just random people
on the street that you going up and
bother and who never asked for any of it
I I just can't rock with it this is not
for me Coy was found not guilty of
aggravated malicious wounding and guilty
of shooting into an occupied dwelling
because this happened inside the mall I
I would not have felt any type of way if
you unloaded a a whole clip into you
guys would not have cared at all would
not have cared at all I don't know just
maybe I'm weird raised weird maybe I'm
maybe we just don't do that to strangers
then I'm we don't do that to strangers
where I'm from hey yo if my
mom learned that I was doing that the
whooping I would have got and his
parents are doing what oh my son is
doing a great and they were making a
video in the mall and trying to have fun
with people and this guy wasn't having
fun and and uh there was a phone that
was around him and and um they were
interviewing and were talking excuse me
this is my stuff say it one more time
this is my
stuff what do you mean I fired this no
wait what's going on I scan it you're
taking that from me what what what
excuse me yo what's up wait what
happened I buy those stuff those
groceries those are mine you [__] hit
me you see you water bottle
hey get
off how's it going man disappear from me
okay bro homie tried to fight me over
his paper towels that's actually comedy
but uh me personally like if someone was
trying to take my groceries I'm probably
giving the same reaction I feel like
everybody is not going to let anyone
take their groceries but uh bro that was
that was hilarious
dud n get shot get shot some of y'all
raising menaces expecting everybody else
to feel Sympathy for the fact that you
didn't do a good parenting job I don't
know I don't feel I'm I'm on TV right
now and my mom my mom watching my thing
and be like uh maybe you shouldn't done
that maybe you shouldn't said that maybe
there's a better way to do that the
wording was a bit off you should have if
my the whoop n I'm good I don't even
like comparing these kind of people to
animals cuz even animals don't go around
making themselves a
nuisance anything else you want to say
no all right let us know what you guys
think in the
comments